san marino rm vt lunghissimo allora
solitamente quando ci sono loro due
assaggiamo cibi strani oggi farei una
challenge nuovissima e cioè la challenge
di oggi è cose strane che solo il 10 per
cento di noi per 104 per cento
noi vogliamo l'uno per cento quindi cose
che neanche docs o cose
strass che solo lo fu quel centro di
persone da fare saremo un per cento di
quelle persone
scopriamo subito la prima è toccarsi il
naso con la lingua
[Musica]
andrea è ufficialmente squalificato mi
spiace che un ragazzo troppo farlo ok
toccarsi ea napoli il naso matrimonio
credo di sì ok
nessuno
noi no
no
[Musica]
è colpa vostra ragazzi di voi che avete
obbligando la rete di rosi leccarsi il
gomito e difficile comunque avevamo
detto lui riesce più o meno io o meno io
no ragazzi fate qui si spappola ok lui è
riuscito tu no
terza cosa strana guardare in due
direzioni differenti quindi un occhio
guarda dritto e l'altro guarda da
un'altra parte proviamo io so farlo ok
vediamo
e questo ci sta stupendo no provo io
come si fa a diventare così come fai
bisogna innanzitutto saper far così
ok che poi solo che lo fi mentre guardi
la t shirt e lo sai fare
passiamo all'altra non dividere le dita
cioè così ci riesco finalmente c'ero io
sono molto più difficile per fai così e
leggibilità così riesco fra barbiano che
non riuscì nemmeno prima va bene questa
è la seconda vittima tuschi questo è
impegnativo perché perché bisogna da un
lato girare in senso orario
la nostra bambina ma allo stesso tempo
contemporaneamente disegnare un 6
[Musica]
dai sigg ce lo abbia o meno fatto è un 6
variopinte fratello edoardo io allora
[Musica]
bene ovviamente meglio di salerno ma
raina d'altra parte lui hanno tirato
così no io ho fatto l'orario il mio no è
difficile ragazze con più di 6 anni fa
molto male
partiamo passato dai ragazzi forse altre
proporsi arricciare la lingua io questo
non sa farlo cioè mai riuscita mai ci
riuscirò tutte sa fare io sono per
acquisire lingua
ma quando si è pronti con una mano tap
tap sulla testa con l'altra dei cerchi
sulla pancia ma tutto ciò
contemporaneamente ok allora bravo fatto
era giusto
[Musica]
ok io non sono sicurissima deve severo
nostro piano questo dico questa è
veramente difficile perché dobbiamo con
le braccia a rosarno ogni braccio in
direzione diversa quindi
contemporaneamente quindi questo va
avanti e questo va indietro giusto
ecco la prima falla fallo su difficile
logico riuscire ad oggi devo riuscire
allungare le braccia etto cars i gomiti
quindi io sono quella scusate che si
avvicina dai più è diciamoci la verità
[Risate]
pollici appiccicato al polso questo io
credo
[Musica]
ora io devo dire che manca veramente
molto poco
anch'io aspetto cm salerno come al
solito vince aveva anche veramente
[Musica]
[Risate]
muovere le orecchie e la vedo immobile
proprio io allora ho iniziato più morte
di un morto ma no no di tipo piegare la
falangetta dedito del bellini piegare la
frangetta dell'indice allora da così
andare dritto e affusolato l'omicio
incrociare le braccia e gira la testa
qui dentro
io pure
[Musica]
c'è tanto da entrata eyes mollato le
mani ok allora mentre edoardo continua
provate perché ricordiamoci che la
speranza è l'ultima a morire
dichiariamo vincitore ufficiale di
questa challenge me stessa no va bene
forse per questa volta possiamo fare uno
strappo vince andrea ma per poco come
insomma segno di riconoscimento per
questa vittoria deve fare tutti i gesti
che abbiamo fatto fino adesso
contemporaneamente fai un secolo fateci
sapere qui sotto quante di queste cose
siete riusciti a fare esso assicura che
avrete fatto meglio di eduardo presente
perché ci vuole poco
allora siamo molto divertiti vadis avere
sia piaciuto anche a voi
e se ne vorrete altri ribadiamo un bacio
con tutte le mani ma in direzioni
diverse
[Musica]
ciao
adoro al esaltiamoci così storti
[Musica]